it was britain's deadliest terrorist
bomb
now the suspected bomb maker is in the
frame
reports in the united states suggest it
will seek the extradition from libya for
trial
of abu aguilar massoud this almost 32
years
to the day since 270 people were killed
and their families bereaved if you have
a much-loved elder daughter who gets
murdered and you feel you don't know who
murdered her and so on
um every day you remember her you
remember
what she would have given to the family
and what she would have given to
medicine she was a very bright young
doctor
and i think she would have had a
fantastic career in front of her
all that was lost in that moment
of atrocity only one man's ever been
convicted of the lockerbie bombing
abdel bassett almagrahi was jailed then
freed on compassionate grounds
after he suffered cancer he was accused
of operating on behalf of the qadhafi
regime
were the two suspects acting under
direct orders
from you
the late dictator denied a role in
lockerbie but he'd handed over mcgrath
for trial
amidst punitive u.n sanctions mcgrath
passed away in 2009
mcgrath died protesting his innocence
the fight to clear his name has
continued long after his death
in recent weeks here a panel of scottish
judges has heard a posthumous appeal
on his behalf they're due to issue their
findings shortly
lawyers from mcgrath say the timing of
developments in the united states
is no coincidence they point to the
personnel involved
behind the latest move is outgoing u.s
attorney general bill barr
as a younger man 30 years ago he held
the same position
when lockerbie charges were first laid
why wait until the eve of the law could
be bombing anniversary
why wait nearly 32 years after the
bombing
why would the attorney general who steps
down this week a man who framed the
charges against
abdul bassett al-magrahi 1991
wait until this week a few days shy of
the anniversary
to say that they want to indict mr
massoud
monday sees the 32nd anniversary of the
lockerbie bombing
investigators have always said it was
the work of more than one man
putting one other man in court should be
a step closer to justice for all
concerned
though not all are convinced james
matthews
sky news